thanks um
so i'm a bit rusty it's a long time i
didn't do a training with many people so
like after three years so maybe we can
you have to be gentle with me
but you have the right to ask as many
questions as you want uh
i mean the purpose is that
this is kind of so interactive and that
you get outside that cycle you learn
something
um
so the way that i will do
will be that i will give you a bit of
information where basically to get
the materials if you want to run those
experiments on your laptop
and i will just make then a 10 to 15
minute presentations just to see like
the concepts that i will like present
afterwards and then i will just directly
go inside each one to say okay what are
we going to see like completely okay
i put on a
discord
a link in the room a1 on our a0506 yes
to
a github repository
so otherwise you can go to my account
with the dynamette and then you will
find that the latest updated repository
will be this one
and
there i have two things so
i have in two formats i have some
notebooks so there's four notebooks four
topics that we will see
and i also have them in format of
a python script directly because
actually i'm using vs code usually with
a gp text where you have markers on that
you have the interactive windows so like
this you can choose one of the overs
you are free to do so here i will use
the notebook because it will be easier
to see
and and to to manage with the fonts
and the
i put a file with a requirement that
library that we'll need
so just for infos
we will need scikit-learn pandas
seabourn jupiter for running the
notebook if you need them and then shop
for the last notebooks
so no more than that okay that would be
enough
and uh
i don't know if that would work for the
last because i just checked now
i created a binder normally that would
install those things i would advise you
to do this on your own laptop instead of
binder because it's a bit slow but in
case that you have
some trouble somehow
with your machine you might launch a
binder there
um
you might have some difficulty with shop
because i just like saw today
that the version of numpy that is in
style is 122 and for number you will
need 121 so you will need to downgrade
at the moment that you play with the
number of shop if you use binder
okay so
before
to go
in the first notebook
i will take a couple of slides which so
don't worry there's not that many
they're all the same things that i
repeat
so they come from like i give a talk
last week in my ladies in paris and
i didn't do any tutorial but basically i
thought that that could be interesting
to get like the couple of slides that i
have been in such that
we speak about the same
some topics
here so i'm not in france so pray you
you never read the book which on the
right which is called the limitless
croissants in in in french but in
english is famous books which is called
limits to growth
anybody's
heard about that
one person
two
you should be more because it's a very
very interesting book
uh so maybe for those person can you do
you know what's that here the spaghetti
plots on the on the right
no idea
so this is actually
the word okay so this is a model of
course this is statistical models that
represent how
like for those people that wrote the
books they say okay what we need we need
to have a statistical model to actually
understand some of the dynamics of the
system and instead of because the world
is very complicated what we should do is
simplify it in some way with some
assumption whatsoever so we take some
hypothesis we create a model so they
created that type of model and then from
that they say
okay
i have my model f
i have some input x that i that i can
define then i want to understand what
will be the trend in the next
20 years
uh 60 years etc
so
i created the the
those people
what they did if you want you can play
you have a python library that does that
okay but the book was written in the 70s
and and
they were really interesting about like
two major things understand
the dynamic of different
inputs and how they will interact
between each other
and then
actually create
several scenarios to know for instance
until when can we pollute the planets
until that this is growing up or until
it is sustainable how much the
population can grow until that it will
not affect another
variable etc so they are using it in a
very different way than what actually
will do afterwards
in in but it's still a statistical model
they don't use it for making like say
predictive modeling like we usually do
in machine learning okay instead what
they do is that just create different
scenarios they are not interesting about
being the most reliable possible like uh
the next day okay to predict what will
be the pollution like tomorrow what they
want is to have a resolution of 10 20
years and see the different uh scenario
and see what what can happen and for
instance this book when it comes out
was quite
famous in the 70s because it's something
that said
if we continue on the way that we are so
business as usual
because we have limited resources and
because the planets have uh is not like
have infinite resources we are going to
be in trouble in 2020 okay so here we go
so now is since the 70s we know
something like this with that
modulations
we have maybe to change something
so
this is just to show that actually a mod
what we call a statistical model
could be considered as a black box but
actually there's kind of some parameters
inside
and usually what we're interested is
to
understand what what those things are
doing and not only we are not only
interesting about
predicting the output but as well what
we have inside this model how and how
it's behaving okay
so
what we'll see today is more prem of of
predictive modeling and not like trying
to make experiments and scenarios etc
our task is a bit different is that we
gave us at hand some data
and our goal in that case is if i have a
new data point
i want
i want
a model that
predicts
uh with the least error possible uh this
new data i mean like what is the output
of this new data point okay
so if i would be in in the regression
like on the left
uh i so this is like some data about
some penguins so if i give a penguin
that i measure the flipper length
i would be interesting to basically give
his body mass but as close as possible
of what it is in reality okay
if i having classifications the penguin
could be a species
and then i could have a different model
that will
given like killman length and the
killman depth that will give me
basically the the species of the penguin
okay
however when you have these things
it comes back as well to the model part
so the modeling part is
you can choose
a complex model or simple models
it's it's up to you when you do your
design the thing is when you do a
simple model usually this is easier to
understand how it behave if you have a
difficult model like a very complex
model it's much more complicated to
understand what happens inside
and all the talk of today will be to
show like the couple of tool that way in
circuit learn that given a predictive
models you can try to understand it and
more importantly what i will just like
present is all the trap that you can
have depending on the type of models the
thing that you should be aware that
to not lie to yourself when you try to
inspect it
so
because of the classification of where i
will come i will just present like three
let's say classification of
of of the meta that we use to actually
explain what else so first you have two
type of of
you i mean like two type of methods one
that is model specific so if you have
linear models
you can only apply that method to this
specific type of models or three models
of you have model agnostic so it doesn't
matter what you have you will just take
like the prediction function of your
models and try to explain for example
what is the prediction
how did it come to
to to this answer
so you have model specific versus model
agnostic
the second thing is
that you can have some explanations
which
you try to explain a single data point
and why did you take
a decision
for that data point so for instance you
have a client that came to ask you alone
you didn't give him the loan basically
you have the right to ask you why you
didn't give me give me this loan and
then you need to come with an
explanation for that particular
customers
otherwise you have some global
explanation which is for my full data
set for my pool full of
my pool of people
what is more or less
the attributes that have an influence
basically on why did i took that
decision for this
bunch of people
so these global versus local
and finally it's something that will go
a bit more into details
uh so usually we
never
like look at these problems in details
but it is also what does your
explainability method is actually
evaluating because they can evaluate
several things he can evaluate actually
the function f so you model itself given
a data point and then you will make an
expression with this but actually you
never use the true targets okay the true
predictions so that would be for
instance sharp thus take a model f
take an example x and tell you it's
changing compared to the average
predictions it's changing in these
manners is how i decompose the things
but at never at any point you say hey
the true prediction of that point is
actually this one is it a good
prediction or not actually we never look
at it okay
so that's why you have the other part
here
where you don't give a single data point
so you don't give only the x but you
provide as well the true y
and for instant you will measure
things like the decrease in accuracy
that you have when you make some changes
in your models and just that you i mean
easy model like behaving properly or not
okay so you you take this the invention
into accounts so usually it's like do
you explain only the model
or do you explain the model plus the
data together okay
and here just on this picture so on the
right
seg is a model that does a global
explanation on the left is sharp that
does a local explanation okay if you're
that's why here you have several x and
zero y and here you have only a single x
okay so that's just for
why i have this image here
however
you should be careful about two's aspect
and that's my two concluding slides but
they are super important
so first is you can explain whatever the
type of model that you fit it
or like that you are using
if you have a very bad model in
productions for instance you can still
explain
what
it gives you okay
because you will you can inspect it you
can check what are the parameters inside
trying to understand but there's nothing
that stop you to say actually my model
was [ __ ] from the beginning because
it was just randomly giving me
predictions okay
and the only way that you need to
sometimes ensure is you need to evaluate
your model before to actually try to
make it explainability because if you
just
what you have to understand is that you
explain the model and maybe a bit of the
data but most of the k most of the time
you never i mean you have to make the
evaluations beforehand
so this family here on the right usually
might help you
but you have only very few methods that
actually does this use a true way okay
and the second thing is that
an association
is not a causality
okay so that's maybe the most important
things whatever will come today
i will not tell you i mean really we'll
get some weight to some features saying
like micron here is very important in
some way to explain
my why and as a human we just always
come by to say oh so it means that x
just causes y and then this is
completely wrong okay so here i give us
simple examples that come from
some slides from a tutorial from
somebody from twitter actually
which
is really interesting so if we look at
like the distribution of the data of
those three different python code that
generated those data the distribution is
actually the same okay so if i look at
the drawing distribution this is exactly
the same things
however if i look at the code here
i created x and then from x i created y
so x causes y okay
here i did it in another way i created y
and y just
created x
and then here i did in another where i
just created the variable z that has a
causes on x and on y so
in term of
causal graph you have something like
this so x have a cause on y
y have a cosine x and z are the cosine x
and y but at the end all of those have
the same distributions and you have to
think that here if
y is a variable that i want to regress
given x
so if i write a bit of cyclone code i
will get this okay linear regression
that fit x y then predict x
i will get this fit okay i will get
a regression line that will be the same
for the three data sets and i don't have
anything that tells me
what is causing x or what is causing y
okay i don't have any causality there so
it's just to give you
a sense that always be careful in the
interpretations because you don't
apart if you do a real causal inference
model and and interpretation then yes
you can do that but where is here we
will never
speak about causations
okay
is there any questions
because now we'll play with this with
there was one question from earlier
how's the performance of the world 3
model
the performance so
as i said
on the pi world free models
they don't try to they don't measure the
accuracy of the model they do some um
some scenarios
of what would be with the different
value where do you get
what you show is that the model that in
the 70s that they're dating in in 2000
with the variables that we could observe
up to now where it will go
at the 10 years
let's say
like 10 years visibility
they were very very close
to
what actually happened okay but here we
are not speaking about uh is a
is a popul
if the population was exactly at the
same level it could have been like with
a couple of
thousand people away okay so we still
have like a big difference
but the trend was
right okay so they have already like
during 30 years they look at are the
different trade and
confirming what what what we were on
this aging like 30 years earlier okay so
in that regard the trend are correct
uh
but then we are not uh at the close we
don't try to make very like the right
prediction at the given year
okay
so
if it's fine then we can start
and play with the notebooks
okay so either if you are a git expert i
mean you get users you can clone the
repository otherwise be aware that in
github you always have a download zip
okay so you can just download the zip
unzip on your laptop and then you will
be fine
then for me i will need a terminal
i have locally
the course
on my desktop i think
and i will launch basically the
notebooks here just to have like the
the right
only a single screen
development things
but be aware that you can use vs code if
in any case as well
so if you go in notebooks
so today i will present
first
i will present three notebooks that will
use scikit-learn because so in psychic
learn if i retake the class the
different classification that we show
in scientific learn we do only global
explanation we don't do any local
explanations okay so
i will just
like present the different thing that
does global explanation and i will show
first something that is model specific
that has a linear model usually we
i mean if you have a problem that you
can solve with logistic regressions
why not using a logistic regression this
is a simple model and then we tell you
usually
just look at the coefficients and then
you will understand so
which feature
just have an impact on you why bigger it
is better it is okay so here i will as
well present some pitfalls that you need
to be aware with those coefficients
because there's like some corner cases
that
you have to be careful
and then i will present two different
methods which are more about modal
agnostics so you can use them with any
type of models
one that
will do what we call partial dependence
and we'll show you like one feature with
your target and how they are linked
and another one with permutation
importance
and this permutation importance is um
so it's to to
the same is to basically any model you
can
check like the original variable that
you have how important they are by doing
uh basically the permutations of the
feature so i will come into details and
i will contrast it with something that
we have from a long time ago in psych
learn that are usually why people were
using random for us at that time so then
we have like an attribute that is called
feature importances
that i will just explain why you can use
it
but under some circumstances and what
are the pitfalls as well of using it
okay
that you should be aware don't worry i
got a phd because of that so you can
still and and finally i will get uh into
shop so depending on how much time but
basically i have a basic we we start to
look at this library in inside learn
uh again to comment what are the
pitfalls so i have a couple of them
uh
and and basically we can discuss about
that like a round so this is the first
time that i use a notebook so there is
probably like some other things but if
you have any question that would be
interesting to see if you are using also
like in your work
what you think about it
but we try to get some documentation out
of
all this
so let's first start with
the linear coefficients
i will just
uh adrien
what time do we finish already i what
that what time did we start just
left
okay
good
okay
so the first thing that we'll check now
is is
how linear models because you rates are
like simple models so maybe before that
i start how many people is just to know
how much people are using cyclic learn
how many people
oh yeah use scikit-learn first
yeah great okay you didn't mess up the
room
then is in science land how many people
doesn't know what is a pipeline
okay i'm impressed okay how many people
already used a column transformer
a bit less okay
so how do
okay i will just do
a quick recap of what is a pipeline in a
single line i will just do a cross
validation just that everybody is up to
speed okay
on toy datasets and then i will come
in the notebook so
i will use
a dataset that is the iris dataset
and usually we have two variables x
which is the data required the y which
is we want to predict
so i will just
not that
and the first thing that we would be
interesting most prairie is to
make a models and learn something so
that after that it's predicting but
usually what we want is what we do is
that we use cross validations so we do a
trend split we learn on the training we
just predict and then we check what are
the preferences on that testing
and the code validation is that we
repeat this with a specific strategy
that defines how we are splitting the
data into training and testing
so here i will use this cross
validations
that is provided in
the cross validate that is called cross
validate okay
and i will use a simple model
that we'll just see afterwards
that will be your logistic regressions
okay so my model could be
logistic regressions
and to evaluate that model i can call
cross-validate
passing the model
the full x and the full y and for
instance here i will use a capfold
no it would be a stratified scaffold
where i will do five splits and every
time i will then repeat five times the
same experiment but i will take
one fold for testing the other one for
for for fitting my model okay and i will
just change every time i will just
change the
the testing fold okay so i will have
five different score
so if i do that and store the results
i get
something like this with a nice
message that you should never ignore
okay
and i will come back to that
yeah so then here i can use
pandas to make a data frame such that at
least
you will observe
something that look nice
pd.data frame
of the severe results
okay
okay so here i have one two three four
five five results that correspond to my
fivefold every time i took a portion of
the data to test the model
so here why i say you shouldn't who you
should take care is that here i have
something that say oh my model didn't
converge
which is not normal does anybody have
knows why
any clue
so and yes and why does it don't find
the solution here do you do you know
okay it could be but here is not the
case because basically this model is a
convex model so
at some point you i mean you need to
know a bit but like these log loss so
you will find uh a unique solution at
some point but the problem is that this
is used using lv lbfgs which is called a
kind of gradient descent algorithm so
the problem is that those algorithms are
thinking that every feature should have
kind of the same scale okay if you don't
have the same scale
then the feature with a large large
scale will be attracting basically the
gradient so actually what i'm doing is
like if you see a curve like this i'm
just going around like this because
basically there is one gradient that
just attracts everything and then it's
just much slower to get to the optimal
solutions
so one potential solution here is
written what is written afterwards
either you
just let you argue them more time to
convert to the minimum and then you will
get you will not get the warning anymore
or you can try to scale the data and
that's why you want to introduce that
because then we need a pipeline okay so
what is the purpose of of scaling the
data with a pipeline is to say
i take my training and the idea will be
to make all the feature on the same
scale so i will just divide by the
standard deviations and i will as well
in the same time center them so like
this they will have zero mean and the
standard deviation of one for each of
the columns in x okay so i will have to
learn the mean and the standard
deviation on the training data and then
reuse the statistic to standardize the
testing set or the tuning set okay so
you see that basically you will always
have this
learning those statistics during fit
applying them at some point before to
actually give them to the logistic
regressions
and
the pipeline will allow to not have to
bother manipulating the data but you
just have to say you will apply this
standard scaling and then you apply me
the logistic regressions
so
let's import first this magical
scalar that we call standard scalars
and
now i will declare that i don't have a
single
logistic regressions but
a sequence
and this sequence will be
first
a standard
scalar followed by
a logistic regressions
okay and if i do that
the warning disappear
i cannot say if
actually it has a huge impact on the
output or not okay maybe we just didn't
converge but we are very close to the
solution and at the end you don't see
anything again that's that's a
possibility
so here i just introduced what we call
in cycling a pipeline
and here i use the cross validation and
you see this is handy because then this
model is still behaving like a predictor
you have a fit and a predict and it does
thing in the middle that transforms the
data for you
and if i would fit on
so here you should never do that but if
i fit on some data
you might get the following thing so a
pipeline visually look at that okay so
is the standard scalars one that the
data are pass here then they are
provided to the logistic regressions
that make
you
what what you expect
and this model inside hitler
is behaving like a list so if i say zero
it means that i will get
my standard scalars if i say minus one
it will just correspond to my logistic
regressions okay
okay so
i think i'm using the the master branch
of cyclone that's why but otherwise in
between
you can
so now it's by default in the next
version it will be by default that you
will get that in the new version will be
in the current version you need to type
the following so in the over notebooks i
put it but here
so you need to import escalant and then
you
specific say that you want to use to get
the diagram otherwise you get a string
okay
okay so here it was just like already to
know a bit about like the pipeline so
now i will do in the exercise at some
point i will just use what we call a
column transformer
and i will explain what these things is
doing
at that point okay so i will not
complexify the example here so if you
understood this you already like to to
get the other part so
do you have any
questions no clear
is there a way to use interpretation and
evaluation of model to spot data leakage
problems
that's a good questions we i mean for
sure we don't have
but
basically what will happen is really
when you leak some data that you get a
much better score than what you are
supposed to do
oh okay so that allocate is exactly what
i did
down there when i did
that fit
and why
and for instance if then i ask
the score of x and y so we
usually what we i mean what we always do
is we
keep a part of the data that we suppose
that we never saw during the training
to basically find the eaper parameters
of the model okay so if at some point
we use some of the testing data
in the training process then is what we
call a data leakage if you do that it
means that you will make the life easier
to your model because imagine that you
have a model that learned by her data
points if he never sees the testing he
will never be able to predict them if
you licked a couple of data inside your
training then
the thing that is learning by hurt is
capable of of predicting those points
okay so then you will get for instance a
very good score
while your model just learned by hertz
basically the testing set
so that's why when you do
cross-validation here we do validations
to ensure two things so first is that we
have a training and testing that are
separated so this we could do it with a
single split
but a single split will give you one
score so we say like you have one point
estimate and that's not super good
because
it doesn't give you any information on
what happened if i just shuffle i mean
was i lucky or not and like you cannot
answer to that questions so to answer to
that question is just repeat your
experiment okay so by experimenting
again and again so with the
cross-validation we mix things uh over
and then we get as well an uncertainty
score okay so here i have five score so
i could repeat again and again this is
the same thing and then i could get 100
score i could have a distribution of the
score
and
see for instance like the standard
deviation of this to be how certain
am i that
this type of model can feed the data
in your questions
yep so is that the
overfitting consequence of the data
leakage or is it the same same thing
so
yeah is there
so i will answer like this so is there
the overfitting is induced by the data
leakage or not
no no it's too different concept because
you can over you can make a model
overfit
without leaking data in that case it's
just for instance
a model that learned by earth the data
training is a model that overfit because
the learning specific rules are training
and is not capable of of replicating
this on testing so
the data leakage usually will just tell
you that actually your testing is good
as well
okay so you will just lie to yourself
then like a model that overfits is a
model that have a very high score on the
training set and the very low score on
the testing set while the total leg is
like the score is good on both of them
okay so this is
difficult to detect but usually it's
just like you should ask yourself is it
normal that i get that
that very good score
but this is let's say using a pipeline
like this
plus some cross validations
basically in cyclone we use this
pipeline to avoid any type of data
leakage
if you did some pre-processing before we
cannot ensure that that part you didn't
do any leakage okay but at least this we
can avoid some
some some data leakage that are easy to
mess up when you
transform your data and you keep track
of the data
okay
so now let's go in in the prems and in
the so for them i just show like how you
can for instance
plot i mean fit
logistic regression but now i will go
into details how you can interpret that
models
so let's import
some
data so here i have my things to show
the diagram
and the data that i will use is
the data from openml
which are data so we can look a bit more
at x
so there are data that are coming from a
survey
where we have different information so
we have
two type of of data one that we call
numerical because they are numbers
and and continuous numbers
and some others which are here
categorical and
in that case
the category are
encoded with strings for the moment okay
so we have those two type of data
that one
so
here we have a couple of statistics that
we can already describe and look at what
it looked like and if we look at like
the five first line we will observe the
following
uh
and basically every line will be a
person's okay and for that person we
have an associated values that we try to
so the target that we try to predict and
here this is the wages the wage
which are in uh dollars per hours and
those data from the
80s or 70s or the 75 i don't remember
it's it's old
okay
so basically is the the goal here is not
so before we did like a classification
frame here this is a regression program
okay we try to predict the wage in
dollars per hour
which is
some
something continuous
so for the moment
i take
so i will try to explain a single model
so i will not try to do any cross
validations is to simplify a bit what we
will
manipulate but we can always think about
like how should we do inside the closed
validation settings but here i will just
make a single 20 split
and
the first thing as a human that we
usually do and is to contrast i want to
contrast basically this analysis with
what you obtain with the model okay as a
human usually what we are thinking we
have difficulties to think about with
more than two dimensions first okay
and usually the way that we're thinking
is what we call we make a
i mean
we try to find a marginal representation
so we try to look at one feature compare
to the target okay so i will take for
instance the education level of people
and then on the
bottom axis here this is a wedge and
then so for instance i will say oh so
apparently to get like a higher wage
it seemed that you still have a trend
that you need to get like uh
higher educations okay so but here what
we are thinking is really
one feature the target and we just like
map like those two dimensions we
discarded all the other dimensions okay
and we'll see later on that linear
models for instance doesn't do that it
does what we call conditionals
so by observing this we could like
get a bit of of information and it is
always like interesting to look at your
data so the first thing is like if we
look at the target
you can see that the weight here
so the that's the histogram of the wedge
here there is a kind of long tail
and sometimes we prefer to have uh
more of a gaussian target okay instead
of of like a long tail thing so
we might just like re-transform
basically the distribution so that we
apply
a log basically on that things almost at
the time that we fit it
and then we just denormalize after that
okay so we can we'll see when we do the
pipeline but basically we'll
do a transformation on the target
and praise the second thing which is
really interesting is like this thing is
here
okay this this bunch of points
so if i look at this point here so it
means that
on these y-axis i have the experience of
people and on the bottom axis i have the
age of people and they are all aligned
on a diagonal
so when you do something like this this
means that your data are created okay so
older you are usually more experienced
you get or we can put in the way more
experience you get is usually you're
older you are okay you cannot be
a phd and be two years old normally okay
so normally i didn't give like 15
because it can happen
um
but so here that means that okay okay i
have this quality data and we'll see
that this is actually something
interesting that you have to consider
when you explain your model because it
will have an impact on the coefficients
okay so just by looking at already a
subset of the data we could have already
like figured out
before to have like uh just looking at
our coefficient without looking at the
data
and it's probably a good thing sometimes
just to look at look at a couple of
descriptive statistics of your data sets
and then like if we look at the edge so
we can see okay we have a kind of
slightly
positive
slope and but i mean it's difficult to
to find anything
yeah
um is the standard scalar plus cross
validation leakage free that is like
will standard deviation and mean
correction just be calculated for the
respective faults
exactly
that's why we do a pipeline so if you
use yourself the standard scalers and
you manage yourself the data and then
you can leak
the
the pipeline in psychic learn where you
put those elements are leakage free so
you cannot do any mistake because
or we do the mistake for you but i don't
think we have a bug okay
uh
i'm sure that there's nobody
and
and that's why we always i'm starting by
that things in the course because
sometimes people don't know about the
pipeline
and this is actually the most important
feature of cyclic learn okay so this is
uh
use it
even in the consolidation settings
because that would overuse some trouble
okay so now we just have a broad view of
what are the numeric things and we have
these details about asian experiment
that i will come back later on because
we were a discussion about that
so
i told you that we have two type of data
and i could have fine with pandas
because if i use like the
survey.data.info
and i look at the
d types i have some floating numbers
uh which here are linked
to like a numerical quantity and then i
have those categories so
we already know in advance like somehow
openml offers like some information to
say those columns are already categories
so
pandas have a specific d type which
called category that say that okay here
you have infinite numbers of categories
so this is pretty handy
and we hope that we can leverage that
detector in the future in cyclistry
so here we can only kind of use it and
the thing is
that we want with a linear model i mean
we have to treat differently
the
the
numerical values and the categorical
values
so why is the categories values if you
use them or if you take like let's say
there's one specific way that you could
just uh simply
transform the string into a number is to
say every category is mapped to a
different integer okay
in linear model this is detrimental if
actually
uh
the mapping like the difference between
categories doesn't have an order or
doesn't mean anything
so for instance let's
give like
an example with cars
if you have a blue red and green cards
it doesn't matter which category i mean
that and that you're replaced by like a
number so you have blue that will be
zero red that will be one and green that
will be two
but it doesn't mean so because of the
linear models normally when you go from
zero to one you have an increment of
decrement of the coefficient on the
predictive values
and here it doesn't mean anything to say
because i'm going from
blue to green that i i have for instance
an increase of the price of the car okay
so it's not like
you don't have an order something that i
have an order for instance is like i
know the size of the t-shirt
instead we have a t-shirt which is m
l
excel xxl so those are an orders and
maybe like if i change of one size it
means that
the person is 10 centimeters
taller okay so every time if i change
like if i pass from s
to l so it means like i have an
increment of 40 centimeters so here
there is a meaning of orders and of like
uh
like increments
a regular increment of the value of the
coefficient between the
between the change
so seeing that
usually this is not the case
we don't want to use so this is what we
call ordinary encoders so instead what
we do is that we will just make uh one
not encoder so it means that
every category will be mapped to a
single columns and when the category
appear we will put a one otherwise this
is zero okay so it means that actually
we'll have one coefficient by category
and it means that being that category
will be receiving a coefficient that
will mean that for instance when you
have
a red car because we have to paint it
because it's not white then you will
have an increment of price in your cars
of 300 euros and if you take your car
and that is red but metallic then it
will be 600 euros but that will be
another column so we can affect a beta
at each of the columns okay
so you can always as well i mean it's
just that this is less efficient because
you have much more columns but here you
have a different beta
so we could always think i mean in
general in the linear model you can
always use the one hotend colors
to do this type of managing the
categories okay this is a good things to
do
in the tree
you can i mean just because i'm speaking
about the linear model in the trees you
can use the ordinal encoders you will
not get into trouble
so now
i have
so then to do something for the
categorical data i want to create this
matrix with some zero and one that is a
one out and then on the one i want to
apply
my uh standard scalars because we saw
that that can speed up actually like the
convergence okay
that's why we have different columns
that will have different pre-processing
okay so we don't have a thing
a simple pipeline we have really
something that where we want to split
the data that will go in a onenote
encoder and the other part that will go
in the standard scalars and group
everything back and send it to the
logistic regressions
so this is what we call a column
transformer in psychic learn so here we
use make column transformer
what we do we define
the column which are numerical and the
one that are categorical
and then here we can create
a
tuple in python that will say these one
art encoders will be
[Music]
matched to the categorical columns okay
and first
because i want to demonstrate a couple
of things i will not standardize the the
data because i want to see what happened
on the coefficient when we don't stand
to standardize the data okay and now i
will tell you okay you need to
standardize them for specific reasons
uh
and we already saw one there is another
one that
we will see just afterwards
so here instead of using numerical
columns what we say that whatever we
didn't took in the categorical columns
we just let
how they are okay so we don't touch them
they will be aggregated with the new
categorical columns
and this is to avoid to to have like
too many details afterwards
in the column names i mean you can pass
this this part
so this will be our pre-processing and
now we have to plug our logistics
yeah so that's
what this parameter is doing here so
here we decided to say if it
oh yeah so the question is
um do you
because when you encode for instance if
you have a binary value so male female
and you encode with zero and one
uh you will get a column with a male and
current with female and likely one will
be the opposite of the other one they
are just anti-cor i mean these anti-cor
correlated so then this is kind of
useless so you might want to drop one
columns
and in that case you have the keyword
drop that allow you to set the strategy
and here we drop only in the case that
we have binary we could extend that to
more columns because it's true that when
you have all the columns imagine that
you have like five categories you will
have five columns and actually one of
the columns can be formed from the four
verse okay so
uh
so you can
you can you can as well mention it here
so yeah i'm not doing it but
if you don't want to have problem with
creation then you do that yeah
right it's the same concept
yes
so that the drop
is
yeah
so it's really so this drop is really to
like kick out the dummy one of the dummy
variables that is uh
can be found from the overs
and then here so we have a pipeline that
is our preprocessor
followed by a linear model which is a
ridge here
so the reach is just a linear regression
where we don't uh allow the weight to be
uh
like
big for no reason okay so we have a bit
of l2 regularization what we call and
we put this ridge here inside something
that will transform the target before
before the fit so we will apply a log
as a like
like forward functions so is to
transform i told you like this this
solution will long tail so it will just
transform it a bit more like
like two normal distributions
and then we provide uh the
inverse functions to just like
get when we predict to denormalize to
get back to the original scale okay
so this is a
little bit of details here but it's just
to to have a proper
like to have a question why
okay
so now we just fit our data
and the first thing that we should do is
probably look at what are the
performance of my models
so
here we use the uh
the training and the testing to compute
the mean absolute error so here the mean
absolute error will be interesting
because it will give me a numbers that
say that in average
you make
that amount of difference between the
surrey of a person and the true surrey
so let's see what he give us
we'll plot it
so the i mean average mean that in
average
i predict
2.14 above or under the true values
so is it a problem of or not
uh somehow it might be because if we
look at our y here
uh
the random value where prey between like
five ten and maybe i should make an
instagram actually
so let's make just two
so the
that targets
dot east
so that give me a distribution of the
histogram so yeah so here we do a two
dollar errors for value that goes from
zero to two like okay 15 and then i use
a couple of less so it means that we
still have a model that doesn't it's not
really good okay
but we can we'll still try to inspect it
and see what we'll obtain from that but
from the first thing that you should
look at is this this dimension is my
model good or not
and one way that we could do that is to
so we can get those information and then
if we have a not so many data we can
just plot the true data versus the true
predictions
and here we can so if everything would
be perfect it would be on the diagonal
okay
whatever is like further away i mean
that is where we commit the errors okay
so here we make a lot of errors
apparently for
the high salary okay
so
it's not because so it's like there is
like some hot layers there and probably
this is kind of difficult to to
like to predict them with the
information that we have
so let's start to look at our
coefficient
so seeing that we have a model
so the fit of x-train and y-train
we can plot we can access the regressor
coefficient okay so it will be the value
of the input data
but i thought that i corrected that
yesterday
okay
is this working for every one here
okay cool
okay i'm surprised but yeah
i i thought it was only in the last
release but maybe because we use a one
or two encoders so he's fine he's 14
ranked that wouldn't work but i executed
yesterday and i didn't go to the back
but okay so yeah
the work around
we'll see in the next notebook if
because basically
uh in the up to this version of cyclone
we don't manage very well the name of
the columns and we lose them somewhere
so from next version basically you will
just have to use that this kit feature
names out and you get it from anywhere
in the pipeline okay before you needed
to know in which order your column
transformer was working to create the
names
so yeah
distribution
with a small standard deviation i
understand that you can predict it
better again before the values are right
small range
and here we have a positively skewed
distribution and you said that
you went like yeah you did this
operation about the logarithm and then
the inverse to kind of
have a better prediction
it is more
so i don't remember really about the
theory
but if you might assume that basically
the target might be like gaussian
distributed i mean to get
the right estimator so here the the the
the distribution is not gaussian i mean
it's this one so this is the tail
yeah so basically when you put the log
you will make it more gaussian
then you fit on that data that is better
suited for the model so then you will
predict that you will predict in the
change scale
okay in the log scale and then you can
just
like reverse this transformation and you
get like in the original space
okay
you you yeah in the original space so
like this you didn't got into trouble
with a long tail and you just put a
transformation that you can make forward
and backwards without in trouble
okay so here
i can go and
yes wouldn't be lasso or elastic better
to determine future importance without
using
similar packages
we will go at the end of that notebook
about lasso
and i will explain why there is a some
stuff to know but yeah we'll come to
that
um so here
we have a couple of of so we have all
the different categories okay that have
been one out and coded and then we have
the coefficient that is associated with
them
okay
so if we do a bar plot of those values
we'll get something like that
so usually what we tell you is that a
larger
thing that basically we have an input x
that will be multiplied by that
coefficient that will contribute to y so
negatively or positively larger is this
bar more impact he will have on the
target okay this is what these things
means
but there is like one trick here
because if we look at like what we have
here we see that health and experience
doesn't have a larger weight that all
the other categories that might be
surprising because we could expect that
that should be like the the variable
that should really have an impact on the
survey of people
so it's a bit of a confirmation bias
because i know
that they should
but here the reason is that like here's
the value remember that we didn't scale
the data
so if i take only the edge and i look at
this
value here or the age is here
the value has a meaning it means that if
i add
one years to a person then
it certainly will decrease of 0.003
dollars per hours
okay so that's that's what this value
means and the second one the experience
is as well in edge education is in
another unit so it means that all those
values here
are in their like original units so you
can interpret one variable at the time
it has a meaning
but then if i try to say is this
variable less important than
for instance the unit not member
we are not on the same scale so it
doesn't mean anything so i cannot
compare them between them i mean between
them okay so i need
that's why when we scale the data
everybody every variable is uh
between zero and one or other like
standard deviation of uh
of one so then it means that we can
compare the
the coefficient between them
we cannot come back to the meaning of
the coefficients because okay we need to
descale them if we want to understand
what is the meaning of the coefficient
but at least we can compare them between
them i mean between them
so one thing that i could do here just
to rectify the problem would be
i can look at
the training data and look at the
standard deviations
of a feature so per column look at the
standard deviation and now you see that
for the age i have a lot of fluctuations
compared to all the variables and this
is normal because over one are just one
not encoded okay so they have like a
very small standard deviation and age
experience and education that were
numerical values of dynamic range which
is much larger
so if i use this to normalize the
coefficient so by multiplying by the
standard deviations
i would get something like that okay and
now i see that age and experience have
really an impact i mean like if i really
compare not in terms of their uh
original units but in terms of of their
impacts
agent experience will have a much higher
impact than on on the other one
however here it's like trying to correct
something that we should absolutely from
the beginning it would be much better to
just use the standard scalers and then
we can directly compare the values okay
so here is just to show you
okay i could look at the feature
standard deviation and just like have a
plot like this where we see the correct
coefficients there is a second thing
which is a bit surprising
when we
were thinking when we look at that plot
so
here we saw a positive trend so what we
could have expected somehow is more
education you have
better salary you will get
more experience you have better sorry
you will get and
the age older you are better sorry you
should get okay somehow it is what
you have a kind of a trend positive
and now if i look back
at those coefficients
the h tells you that
it's negative so somehow older you get
the you get a lower salary and the
experience is on the opposite side is
saying that
like
better experience you get
okay you get a bigger series and here is
because a model like this doesn't make
you don't interpret it as a marginal
contribution it's not a marginal link
between a feature and the target but the
conditional one so it means that at
so older i am but
knowing that all the other features have
specific values
okay so i can change the edge but also
the feature i've like already given
values for that sample so my model
already learned like a condition that on
a conditioner all the other features so
what you observe here is not a marginal
link but a conditional link because it's
the value condition with all the other
features okay
and
here we observe that thing because it's
because of the
we'll see in a minute but this is
because of the correlations okay
so
why do i say like i'm thinking about the
correlation one of the bad things that
we didn't do here is that how lucky
i mean was it normal or can it change if
i try to beat the data okay so we don't
have any anything that can help us here
with the study that we have regarding
the stability of the coefficient is edge
always negative or sometimes is it
positive or like and the same for the
experience we don't know any of those so
that's where we could run
across validations
and the causality that we use at the
beginning we can pass him an argument
that is called written estimators that
will written us like every estimators of
all the different models and then we can
inspect the coefficient of all the
different models yeah
yeah so you yes
the
so you mentioned that is it's fair to
say that this is only conditioned by the
data i mean that reach because we are
using rage actually is not
only
a problem of conditional
between x and y because we have also we
are forcing the parameters on the beta
to have like the smallest ways possible
so this is true that the
the strength
alpha will have an impact on the value
of the of the of the parameter so it's
not only like
with all the feature constants when the
the you have an alpha for the
realization things become much more
complicated and this is difficult to uh
it's something to have in mind you are
completely right
okay so here we'll perform the same
experiment than before but just making
in a cross validation so get five
estimators and then here
we get the coefficient of
the regressor and we multiply by
the standard deviation of all so here
there's a bit of of of mechanics because
i wanted to get the training set of
every fold and compute the standard
deviation on that specific training fold
because this this estimator was trained
on that training fold okay so i have to
go and pick up the right tuning fold and
not using like the entire data set
so
that's why it's a bit more cumbersome
and if i do that
i mean much easier would have been to
use the standard scalar but it's coming
afterwards
so if i do that i look at the
coefficient now i can look at
a distribution i mean
i have several coefficients i can look
at the distribution of the coefficients
and i will get something like that and
now i am in information about the
variability of the coefficients so for
all the one other encoded coefficients
okay they are very stable
and then we get like two huge bar for
edge and experience so what this
what's this thing is meaning
it means that most of the time okay the
edge is negative and the experience is
easier to compensate
basically over the the edge coefficient
okay so they compensate between each
each other because they are correlated
but sometimes
my model just switch okay you see that
actually
now my experience will be negative and
in that case to compensate i need to
have a positive
edge okay so the bar will be in the
opposite directions so this plot here
informed me that oh to have like this
thing that like just go and are varying
a lot is probably because i have
something in my data and do something
just that shuffling with the data make
that we have a different model and
inform us that actually here we have two
variables that are correlated
okay
so i could convince myself that okay
that's probably some correlation so what
i can do is just drop one of them okay
if they are correlated mean that i don't
need the two variables to be able to
predict i can use only one
and then my model will not get confused
so let's
remove
okay so here this is a plot to show that
it was a former plot but basically that
the
edge and experience are created
and now i will drop the edge from my
model
and i will just redo the same experiment
so no edge anymore but now you see that
the experience become always positive
okay so
actually before we really
had these things that the experience was
compensated for the age
and that's the premise of created
variables here okay
so somebody was speaking about lasso and
so for the one that doesn't know lasso
is a linear model so rich
impose a l2
regularization so he tried to make all
the weight going to zero so
bigger is alpha
more the way it will be put to zero but
you can put as well a constraint which
is a l1 norm which means that
some of the weight should be exactly
zero okay so you should discard weights
so i think there is an example at the
end and in that case you could make a
kind of feature selections okay and
saying for instance it will drop eight
other experience because
you don't need both to predict very well
yes
wait i have to come because
can you please submit them on
slido i will ask them
yeah if you can go on slido.com
and then you do piper
have like it's not fair for the hybrid
okay
what is it
slide.door
slide the door and then you can ask
questions on the website
and then add repeat them
the instructions are also on the room of
the conference on discord
we have a question
in the example that you use standard
scalar um do we have like are there
recommendations for like all the
preprocessing that we have or like when
when they make sense yeah uh so
regarding the type of pre-processing
that you can use instead of standard
scalars will depend on the type of data
that you have so you need somehow to
have
some knowledge about it but
if
so if you have
for instance some outliers in your data
so that are like away from the main
distribution so usually you don't want
to take into account if you scale your
data you will take into account those i
mean they will have a bias on your mean
and standard deviations so you want to
exclude them and to exclude them
you you will just use something like
robust scalar that will just neglect
like data that are far away from these
distributions
and otherwise sometimes you are
interesting of not censoring the data so
you will use something like min max
keller to
uh let's
not max app scaler sorry to let the zero
being zero okay so like this you have
sparse data so it means this is an
efficient format to have a lot of zero
new matrices so you want this impose you
to not
break this parasiti so you want to keep
so you will use max apps scalar
and otherwise there is some time that
you are interesting about having data
between zero and one for some reason
uh
so for instance like you know
images that you you have pixels that are
between 000 to 56 and you want to bring
everybody between 0 and 1 and in that
scale so then you will do a min max
scaler
yep
doesn't gradient descent take care about
the intercorrelations i know that's a
problem for pl assassinators but that
should be solved using gradient design
that's
i have no idea
uh probably not because otherwise that
i mean this is exactly what we have here
so we have a newton
i mean it's between a newton and a
gradient the sun i think so it's suffer
from that
and and the read should somehow reduce
the problems but it's the algorithm
itself doesn't solve the problem
yeah
how do you mitigate the frequency for
categories when a category is uncommon
but very discriminate
but it's normalized will be very small
so uncommand
so
the thing
is you will encode those
those categories anywhere so they will
have a weight
i mean if there's discriminants i mean
at the time that they appear like one
they will have a huge weight so i mean
you will associate a huge weight to
those
the only problem is that you need to at
least have some of the sample during
training to be sure that they appear
in that case this is more of a problem
of
selecting your right training
an example feature my question i'll give
an example
so my point is if you have a category
uh especially it happens i think we have
the artificial categories and you wonder
how much you should actually place them
in some cases uncommon but they really
very strongly by survival if you do a
normalization
then your coefficients are very small
because this case only
because this level has a very low
standard deviation
so
if you saw here we don't normalize uh
yeah so here you say that yeah if we
standardize very unfrequent variables so
basically there are we'll have a very
small standard deviation so they will
become uh
i mean very small
but here we don't standardize the
categories
what is important is that you don't have
a huge
difference feature range
between the numerical and the category
categories but we don't reapply
like a scaling on the categories
so we only want our tank on them
so we don't apply a
new scaling uh
again i think it's something that is
complicated okay i don't i cannot tell
you that for sure you should always do
that
okay
okay so
here we saw that if we drop one of the
variable then
we don't have the other variable to
compensate so then like the experience
and if we would do with a that would be
the same okay h will be always positive
our experience will be always positive
and we don't have this program
so now what happened yeah what i could
have do instead is to put the numerical
a standard scalars in servers just
letting the data pass through and it
would have directly solved my problems
of trying to correct the feature
and we would have get like the same
results in term of performance
and it's just that by default here
without re-multiply i don't need to
re-multiply by the uh
the scaling
and in that case i mean like the
the
those features which were numeric are
inside like range i mean that at one
standard deviations and the other
coefficients are in the scale of the
encoding basically
so that would be
the usual thing that you do with linear
models so you apply one not encoders and
on the categorical data and the standard
scalar on the numerical data and then
you go on okay
about
what happened just before is that we
were using origin with a very small
alpha which means that we didn't apply
any
weights
i mean a very small regularization so we
let the weights being as big as they
wanted so you have to know that when you
play read so
usually you want to use cross
validations you can use read cv to
actually find what is the best value of
alpha in new predictive settings okay
and
you will use like the internal
causalization to find this alpha
and this will have an impact on the
weight because
more regularization you are putting on
alpha
the weight will just shrink okay all the
weight will shrink in that case
so that
then you cannot if you have an alpha and
you try to express it like in the
original scale of the
of the
or the original units i mean if you take
the coefficient and you want to express
them in the original unit that doesn't
have any sense because the alpha is as
well shrinking the weight because this
is this job okay so you you cannot
interpret them in this way
but here if we so if we do this always
go
10 minutes
okay
i should have to a three hours tutorial
so here
we do
basically we are seeking for the alpha
and
this model we just like find the alpha
directly for you and if we look at
for one models at the alpha so for
instance here you pick up like an alpha
of 10 because from the range of value
that were from
10 to e minus 10 to
i mean log of minus 10 and log of 10
this was the best value at the front
and this might improve
somehow the score here is not the case
but somehow you should always tune up
parameters
okay and here
we can see that by just
applying some regularizations
if i if i look at my coefficients it has
an in an impact direction the
coefficient so for instance now the
experience and edge
are both positive so this is difficult
to i mean like the alpha fight for the
correlation somehow
and then like you put like both positive
so this is like uh normally the job of
the regularization as well is to make as
well like your model more stable
okay
and now
yes and of course
if
one that you apply your alpha here
so those uh think that the model now is
kind of constraints and i
just
have like positive values what happened
after that is like if you look at the
coefficient and you do cross validations
you will see that the you i mean the
regularization solve the prime of the
correlations okay because they are and
the standard deviations were like all
all this thing together just like
managed to uh
to reduce the problem that we had before
so i said as i said like we could have
used a lasso cv and here this is an
example where i'm using the same way but
something that will select
some specific feature
and if i use that and look at
the coefficient
so i redo the same thing this is
performing as good but what is
interesting is now looking at the a
coefficient you see that the exponents
have been set to zero okay and some
others have been set to zero so here the
model found that there is no way of
using both variables and you just put
one to zero because of this
regularization part okay
so
one important things with uh
with lasso to know is that here we
picked up experience but there is no
reason we could have picked up
age okay so the algorithm in in cycling
just make a cyclic way of of picking up
things so
you might have more chance that it will
be always the same variable that is drop
but is not a given so to see that we can
just run
a close validation and reproduce
the same things and here we observe
this thing so here we can see that most
of the time h is kind of like positive
most of the time experience is zero and
sometimes
this is not the case okay so one of the
thing is that lasso is not a
superestimator because the algorithm is
unknown as well not stable not i mean
it's not always stable so just by
changing a bit the data
there's some cases here that edge become
like negative and we have the same
problem of creative things so maybe i
could have like increase
the the value of the alpha but then like
is already automatically like set by
cross validation so i cannot like i
would need to do it by hand so this is
not
usually the way that we do okay so you
you want to use lasso cv to optimize
these disappear parameters
okay
so it stays five four minutes okay
did you learn something
maybe
uh
yeah i mean
so one of the questions here yeah
there this is awesome but the other
parts is there a recording in other
places that you've given the talk that
people could watch
i i have to check
i think
the part about permutation importance
and partial dependence there is because
we have in the so i will just give
we have a channel in psychic learn
that should be here
where these talks and i assume that in
those ones is one of olivier grisel that
presents the future importance
and the permutation importance and the
and probably the partial dependence
sorry for the shop
because it was the first time that i was
trying to present it
but we can discuss it as well for the
people that here we can discuss later
does psychid land support beijing
approaches to model uncertainty of
coefficients
yes and no we are very bad at that you
should use pimc3 for that we have two
models which are called bijan ridge and
rd regressor
which
are like proper by asian approach where
you give a priors etc the problem is
that we don't give you the distribution
of the coefficient we just give you the
uncertainty of the predictions
so
we should be able to do that but our api
is not good so play is something that we
should fix because we should be able to
do that
so but i advise you to use like a real
bayesian framework like by mc3 if you
want to do that
thank you
okay three four
[Applause]